good afternoon everybody
my name is michael fee and it's my honor
to host our speaker today eve martyr
who will give the 8th annual philip a
sharp lecture in neural circuits
this lecture series is sponsored by
biogen to honor the many contributions
of phil sharp to our community
these include his role in founding
biogen a leading
biotech company as well as his role as
an intellectual and administrative
leader here at mit
in addition to leading the biology
department and mit
center for cancer research for many
years phil was also the founding
director of the mcgovern institute for
brain research
so it's my great honor to introduce our
speaker today
eve martyr is a university professor and
faculty in the department of biology at
brandeis university eve grew up in new
york city
and developed her scientific instincts
early on
in her biography her beautiful biography
eve recounts how she did her first
scientific experiment at the age of
three
at the 86th street central park
playground
the experiment involved determining
whether her head would fit between
the vertical bars of the railing around
the park
and in this experiment she definitively
proved that the answer was yes for going
one direction
and no for going the other direction so
eve received her bachelor's degree from
brandeis
and her phd from the university of
california in san diego
it was at ucsd that she began working in
the lab of al silverston
and set out to understand the full
complement of neurotransmitters of the
stomatogastric ganglion of the crayfish
after a postdoctoral stint in paris eve
returned to brandeis's junior faculty
where she has been ever since working on
a dizzying array of approaches
to really understand the inner workings
of the amazingly complex circuit that
controls the stomach of the crayfish
using this model system eve has made
fundamental contributions to many areas
of our understanding of neural circuits
including understanding how the same
group of neurons can implement
multiple different behaviors how neural
circuits maintain their function
under strong perturbations such as
temperature changes
and the dramatic changes that occur
during growth and development
she's also found that neural circuits in
different individuals
find dramatically different solutions to
implement the same behavior
in terms of the distributions of ionic
conductances that drive the underlying
dynamics
these findings may have deep
implications to our understanding of the
sources of variability
in how neural circuits respond to
pharmacological therapies
and ultimately how genetic variations
coupled to brain function
for this work eve has been the recipient
of numerous awards
she's a member of the national academy
of sciences
the institute of medicine and the
american academy of arts and sciences
and was recipient of the cavali prize in
2016
among numerous other recognitions for
her achievements
despite all these awards i would venture
to guess that eve is even more proud of
her impact on the many dozens of
students and postdocs she's mentored
over the years
eve is also a tireless advocate for
women in neuroscience
helping our community better understand
the challenges that women in science
face
she also devotes time on the editorial
board of the journal elife
creating innovations in open access
scientific publishing
and the scientific review process
so please join me in welcoming eve here
today
even though applause doesn't work very
well on zoom in my mind's eye
i'm hearing a warm round of applause to
welcome you to mit eve
for your talk today well
thank you michael and i hope all of you
can
see my screen it's a great honor to
be here for the sharp lecture um
it was supposed to be in person so um
i'm really
quite regretful because um since going
to nyt doesn't mean any airplanes i
would have been
very very happy to be there for real um
and for reasons that are
a little bit sort of beyond my total
comprehension
i am completely tore apart this seminar
and put in a lot of new data stuff
that's unpublished
so um hopefully i'll be able to keep all
the threads together
as i weave all this stuff together so
my title however remains the same
differential resilience to perturbations
of circuits with similar performance
and this as michael said comes from
years of work on the stomata gastric
ganglion of
lobsters and crabs no crayfish michael
sorry
he thinks that all crustaceans are
crayfish i think
anyway i'm teasing you however the
difference is lobsters and crabs that
live in the marine environments in salt
water and crayfish are usually fresh
water
but anyway so um
i'd like to start first by just honoring
the people
um the very wonderful people with whom
i've had the pleasure to work my present
lab is there
is up on the up here on the the left
upper left and then there are all these
wonderful people who've
left my lab and gone on to various and
sundry
future careers there are people who are
working in industry
people who are working in government a
large number of people who are now
training people in their own labs is uh
and then people who are
moving along or still postdocs or still
graduate students at various and sundry
places
and then of course i was very very lucky
over my career to have
some totally wonderful collaborators and
in particular larry abbott and his
students who
was very instrumental in our moves into
computational neuroscience
so the problems i'm going to be talking
with you about today include
how is individual variability related to
resilience to challenge
this is particularly timely i've been
doing this for a couple of years but
it's like this year
with the pandemic has raised this to
about the most important problem i can
imagine
and then a problem that i find really
fascinating
and difficult to think about that i
think we all worry about
when and how it changes at one level of
organization percolate to change the
dynamics to a higher level of
organization
so i mean to put this in perspective
when does
changing the properties of a single
synapse or a single cell
when does that actually influence the
circuit in which those neurons or
synapses are part of or when do they
stay more local
to the level of organization at which
they occur
and then i'm going to focus somewhat on
this question of
can we predict when cryptic or hidden
underlying differences will surface
to give rise to untoward or unexpected
state-dependent actions
and i think again this is very very much
part of
our trying to understand individual
variability
um because we see many examples
of in in the human wither in the human
world of people who seem fine and then
some people
have serious stresses and do fine and
other people don't
and so there must have been cryptic or
hidden differences
which surface only in response
to some perturbations and so those are
the ideas that we're going to be talking
about
again in the context of small circuits
now the the small circuits that i'm
going to be using are those of the
crustacean stomatagastric
nervous system and just so that you guys
are fully aware
um we work on mostly right now we work
on crabs is cancer borealis
they live in the atlantic ocean they're
they they're brought in by their
fishermen sometimes
it's the same lobster fisherman they
find the crabs either in separate pots
or the same pots
they bring them to the harbor and they
go to a distributor and we buy them from
the distributor
and that is to say since all fishermen
lie about where they get their catches
we have no idea exactly where these
animals come from or
the temperature of the water which they
were now the animals we work
on are usually five to seven years old
the cancer borealis is about so big
so big i think you can see it um sort of
five to seven inches or something like
that eight inches
um and they've weathered
it's five or six or seven years in the
north atlantic
they've been through the storms and
they've been through the tides and
they've been through
all the above and they have managed to
not get eaten by the seagulls
so i think you should bear that in mind
these are robust and successful animals
the ones we actually get
um and they're as robustness and and
and strong in their own way as all of
you in the audience are that is to say
you've made it through
to adulthood now what we do
is in pandemic days um
one of my wonderful lab technicians
drives down to the distributor and picks
them up and brings them back to the left
because
they used to take a taxi but taxis
aren't allowed on campus
and so then they end up in our tanks
downstairs until
they get sacrificed for use
now the stomatogastric nervous system
controls movements of the
foregut of the animal a lobster crab
stomach has about 40 pairs of striated
muscles it's nothing at all like
the vertebrate gut instead it's much
more
like the vertebrate mouth part or
shoulder in that it's
um we have excitatory motor neurons that
move striated muscles and produce
very specific sets of movements and
these are complicated movements that
move
teeth and ossicles um inside the stomach
it's a very complicated
mechanical device okay so
we take the stomach out of the animal we
dissect the stomach acid nervous system
off the stomach and
pin it into a petri line uh silver line
petri dish
and we super fuse it with chilled
physiological saline or temperature
control physiological saline
we de-sheet the ganglion itself thus the
magnesium and crabs has about 26 neurons
they're about 100 microns the somato
about 100 microns
and so we use sharp electrodes to record
intracellularly from them
and we put extracellular recordings on
the motor nerves
that used to go down to the stomach
muscles
and it's very important that i tell you
that these neurons are
uniquely and unambiguously identified on
the basis of their
peripheral projection patterns so when i
call a neuron an lp neuron it's because
that scent it sent an axon to a muscle
that we call the lp muscle and likewise
all the other neurons are
are unambiguously identified and that's
one of the reasons why this preparation
has been so useful
so when you record simultaneously from a
neuron called the lp one called the py
one called the pd you can see a
triphasic motor pattern
lppypd lppypd lppypd
and looking at these recordings i think
these must actually come from lobsters
not
grabs but um
but it's basically the same exact rhythm
and here on the extra cellular recording
these are interesting recordings
and on the simultaneous exercise
recording you see
over here the x potentials of the lp
pypd
lppypd and the
control rhythm has a period of about one
second
so this rhythm goes on
continuously in the animal at all times
it's so it's like your respiratory
rhythm or your heart in the sense
that it's always on and this makes it
particularly useful
for studying as we look at things that
will influence its behavior
now the the earliest workers
chose this preparation because in vitro
it produces a motor pattern that
resembles very strongly what you see in
vivo
and in fact it's almost
indistinguishable and because this
preparation will live for many many many
hours
we've kept them alive as long as two
weeks um
under the the appropriate conditions so
that means that you have time to do
experiments of all kinds
now the first goal that those early
workers
set themselves was to try and work out
what they called the wiring diagram what
we they call the connectome
because they believed um sort of
spiritually
that once they had the wiring diagram
they'd understand how that how the
circuit worked
so here is the connectome for the
pyloric rhythm
there's a single a b neuron that's an
interneuron it's electro
coupled to two pd neurons there's one
alpena on each animal and there are
five in crabs and eight and lobsters py
neurons
so these black dots are all chemical
inhibitory synapses
so here then is the connectivity diagram
if i just show you this connectivity
diagram
there's absolutely no way if you didn't
know what the dynamics were that you'd
be able to predict it from this
circuit diagram by itself and that's an
important thing to remember
because the connectome or the
connectivity diagram is absolutely
necessary
and completely insufficient for
understanding how circuit works and i
think
it's very important that we keep that in
mind if you really want to understand
how a circuit works you have to be
identified be able to identify neurons
and you have to have some version of a
connectome
but the connection alone just won't do
it so how does this work
the ab neuron is a bursting neuron it's
electrocoupled to pd neurons
therefore the pd is firing a burst the a
b and the pd neurons
rhythmically inhibit lp and py and they
fire and rebound from inhibition
so this is a circuit that runs on
inhibition there's no
excitation within the circuit except for
the electrical coupling
and there are many descending modulatory
inputs including amines and
neuropeptides which upregulate the
excitability of
of cells in the circuit okay
but what's clear should be clear to you
by now
is that there's a lot of information
missing in the connectivity diagram of
the wiring diagram
and that is all the voltage and time
dependent currents
in each of the cells and what their
dynamics are and how they interact and
how
those interactions give rise to these
behaviors now um
i think it's precisely as we tried to
really understand a more reductionist
level
how these rhythms arose that grew
that allowed us to start thinking about
using computational methods
and that's how we ended up where we
ended up combining my lab as you'll see
today basically is 50 50 experimental
and computational
but before going on into more details
about the pylori
i want to show you the other circuit
or the other motor pattern the pyloric
rhythm is a fast rhythm it's ongoing all
the time
there's also a second very important
rhythm and this is called the gastric
mill rhythm
and it moves teeth inside the stomach
and it has a period that's about
10 times slower with the periods ten
times longer than that of the pyloric
rhythm
and you can see that here there's a
neuron called
lg it's depolarizing firing a long burst
hyperpolarizing depolarizing
and it's firing in out of phase with dg
over here
and you'll note that there's an envelope
of activity
in these neurons called the icnbd which
is
in phase with the gastric mill rhythm
but the ic and the vd
are two neurons which are also part of
the pylori rhythm
and you can see that here they're firing
at time with the pyloric rhythm
but only in one of the phases of the
gastric meal rhythm
so these neurons are actually i don't
know if multiplexy is the right term
exactly
but they really are multiplexing or
participating in a fast rhythm and a
slow rhythm
and they actually under different
physiological conditions flip back and
forth
between being more profoundly part of
the gastric male rhythm or part of the
pylori
so this is the full connectome
of the sdg and crabs
and what you see here and this is very
important you see all these electrical
junctions
and you can see everybody is sort of all
connected to everybody
and if you start thinking about
electrical junctions in particular
between
cells that are not just copies of the
same neuron you really
realize very quickly that electrical
junctions actually create
all sorts of parallel pathways or
multiple ways in which cells can
interact
and when gabrielle guterres was in the
lab
she was a graduate student of mine who's
now um
uh at the university of washington and
she's moving to columbia and barnard
to start a faculty position um soon i
don't exactly know when she's moving
given the pandemic
but she noticed that there's a five cell
she started
as a physicist there's a five cell
circuit at the heart of this and
it has a tremendous then it has symmetry
so you see pd and lp now notice there's
reciprocal inhibition that's a half
center oscillator
those are part of the pyloric system
there's lg and interneuron one that's
another half center
oscillator reciprocal inhibition and
this is the core
or the center of the gastric mill
circuit but notice
that pd directly inhibits ic but it also
inhibits it
through the lp in this electrical
synapse likewise
interneuron 1 directly inhibits
ic but also there's a polysynaptic
connection through
this electrical synapse so gabriella was
really intrigued by this
circuit because she said i want to
understand
how a cell like i see how its soul would
be controlled
by the war between fast oscillator and
the slow oscillator she wanted to know
how ic's behavior would determine be
determined
by interactions from the fastest level
oscillators so she decided to build
a model of this five cell circuit it's
not intended to be a model
of the stomatogastric circuit per se but
it was motivated
by the structure of the circuit so she
did exactly that
she started out with simple oscillators
in isolation
she has five cells she called f1 that's
a fast oscillator f2 that's another fast
oscillator
these are more slicar neurons they have
calcium currents potassium currents and
an h current
she has that center neuron that she
called the hub neuron
and it's a medium frequency oscillator
and then two slow oscillators s1 and s2
and then if she hooks up f1 and f2 with
reciprocal inhibition they fire out a
phase like you'd expect
likewise s1 and s2 and then if she just
hooked up the electrical coupled
backbone you can see they come in just
into in phase or
sacred knee so what happens when you
connect the whole thing up
and so gabrielle now um connected the
five cell
model together and to show you what's
going on she developed a really
beautiful way of displaying the behavior
these are five concentric circles and a
square
where f1 and f2 that's they're
they're denoting the frequency of the
fast oscillating neurons
s1 and s2 are in the middle those are
these guys
and the square is the frequency of the
hub neuron
this is on a heat map so f1 is fast
s s2 here and s1 are slow
and green their intermediate frequencies
so that's what you see here
and then she's calling the strength of
the synapse the electrical synapse
conductance electrical or gl and the
conductance of
this synapse from s1 to hn
gsin a the conductance of that
likewise gc and b are the strength of
these reciprocal circuits
so with one set of parameters
you can see the circuit now is showing
an orange blue
and it's an orange because the fast
cells
are firing in one frequency and the hub
neuron now
the square is firing with the slow
neurons
so too fast three slow it's one set of
parameters
a different set of parameters you can
see here everybody's green
they're all firing at the same frequency
they all are in relative phase relations
with each other but they're part of
a simple rhythm so
gabrielle wanted to see what the full
behavior of the circuit would be
so she developed what she called the
parameter escape
so each set of parameters you can see
here with this same
way of displaying and if we have now
gcn a that's the synapse the conductance
of
synapse a on the x and the electrical
synapse on the y
you can see this gorgeous gorgeous
gorgeous pattern
and when i first saw this i said
gabrielle i want a blouse and she said
for my thesis i'll make you a blouse and
she did
so i have a blouse made of this pattern
which is and actually she also sent me
masks with this pattern but what i want
you to see
is that as you look
at high gl as you go across
you go through many different patterns
of activity
over here you've got a whole range of
of parameters that give you
qualitatively similar behavior over here
you've got a whole range the
qualitatively similar behavior
but over here you can see you're going
through lots of different transitions
and this allows you to visualize very
carefully what the different frequency
relationships and phase relationships
in the circuit are and it allows us to
say
well if you had a modulator a which
produced an increase in synaptic
strength
over here if you start out in h
even a small change increase in
modulator a
could take you through qualitatively
three different
kinds of behaviors on the other hand if
you start out over here
you have a much larger effective
modulator
a but you could stay within a region
where you're producing
qualitatively only the same behavior so
this is a beautiful example of what we
call state dependent
actions the the same modulator can have
very very different qualitative
behaviors on the circuit depending on
what the starting conditions are and i
think you all knew that but this is just
a very nice way of seeing it
but the reason why i love this paper
is what we call degenerate mechanisms
produce the same change in behavior
so here gabrielle is starting out with
that five cell circuit
with f1 and f2 fast hn is firing slowly
it's firing with the slow ones
and then she decreases gcna and the hn
moves into
concert with the f1 and f2 neurons
then she goes back and now she decreases
gl and again she flips hn into
firing with the fast rhythm and here she
decreased gen b
and again she's able to produce the same
behavior
so this is important for all of you who
try and understand
what changes give rise to what changes
in behavior in circuits
these are three entirely different
cellular mechanisms
that give rise to a circuit response
that looks indistinguishable and i think
it's really really important because if
they were a poor graduate student at mit
who did this experiment they'd you know
be
fast running off to publish a paper and
sell saying i've discovered the
mechanism
by which hm flips from being in this
behavior to this behavior
and they probably get their advisor help
them get their paper published
and some board graduate student at ucsf
would say oh no they're wrong
because look i've done this other
experiment i produced the same behavior
and then the poor graduate student in in
bangalore would do this
experiment and now two other things were
already published
and he would have the third mechanism so
these are
three entirely different mechanisms that
can produce the same change in behavior
and i think since you see this in a
five-celled circuit
it's important to know why you're seeing
it you're seeing it precisely because
of the electrical junctions which create
these parallel pathways
and it's those parallel pathways that
now give rise to
um the multiple mechanisms that can
produce the same
changes of behavior and i think if you
remember nothing else from this talk but
this it's really important to keep it in
mind for those of you who are trying to
understand certain dynamics
and their modulation one more
slide from gabrielle's work and
everything she had done thus far she had
just been changing synaptic strains and
she had left the intrinsic properties
alone
here what she decided to do was
to look at what happens if she changes
the properties of the hub neuron
by neuromodulating it let's say so
here's the hub neuron
it's a wimpy oscillator and now
she increases she keeps the frequency
the same but she increases the waveform
of the oscillator okay so here you have
a much larger
calcium current and so you've got a
large plateau
and then she embeds these four versions
of the hub neuron
into two different circuits they're the
same circuit but they have different
strengths of connections
so over here when she embeds
the oscillator into this circuit
you can see that yes the hub neuron
changes its behavior
but the rest of the circuit is
qualitatively unchanged
however when the circuit's starting
conditions
were different with different sets of
synaptic strengths
now as she modulates the hub neuron
you can see completely different effects
so here you have the hub neuron is fired
with the slow oscillator
and then as you increase the waveform of
the hub neuron
first the whole circuit synchronizes or
this is exactly synchronized but comes
into one frequency
and at the end you can see now one of
the cells
one of the cell becomes silent and the
others all become
firing at a fairly rapid rate now the
reason i love this
this result is it shows you that the
effects of
modulating this one neuron the only one
she's modulating is the hub neuron
will either stay local to the neuron
she's modulating
under these sets of conditions or hear
the effects of modulating this neuron
percolate
and influence the whole circuit and the
only thing that's been different
is the starting conditions or the set of
synaptic strengths
in the starting conditions so i think
this is very very important the circuit
itself is the same
it's the parameters that underlie its
beginning but the
modulation at the cellular level was
identical
okay so i'm going to leave gabrielle's
work
and go to show you
a little bit more about somewhat more
complicated neurons
that we all used relatively simple
neurons as i said they only had three
active conductances in a leak
i'm going to show you some data with
models that are a little more
complicated
these have eight conductances they have
a leak and seven
voltage dependent conductances an inward
sodium conductance
two calcium conductances and h that's a
hyperpolarization activated inward
current
three potassium conductances the delayed
rectifier
calcium activated potassium current and
the a current
okay now the key to the next couple of
slides
is a method that leandra alonso
developed for
basically visualizing what's going on
as these currents all activate and
inactivate so one of the complicated
problems
is being able to visualize
what's going on as many different
voltages and time dependent currents are
turning on and turning off at the same
time
so that's what he's done here
here now we see a bursting neuron
it's hyperpolarized it's depolarizing
it's fighting a burst of action
potentials this is the
a single neuron that's meant to
represent the pacemaker kernel of the
pyloric rhythm but it's any burster if
you will
and now what leandra's done is he's
displaying
outward currents up as we would do in
biophysics and inward currents down as
we would do in biophysics
the total outward current he's shown
here in black
on a very compressed log scale the total
inward current
down here and now we can look at
individual ones
now he's plotting the percent of the
total lowered current carried by each of
these
color-coded currents so let's just look
at purple this is the a
current you can see it's small and then
it's getting larger then it's getting
smaller
whatever in orange we see the calcium
activated potassium current
and you can see it's changing so that
down here
the calcium activated potassium current
is the dominant outward current and the
acorn is only small
um and pink is a leak
and out here you can see the inward
currents the hair is
in green and blue the two calcium
currents and red is the same current
okay
so what can we see if we
look at um using this method so aleandro
has done here
is he's created six models
that are all bursting neurons you can
see their behavior is very very similar
this is at the single cell level
something that astrid prince
published in 2004 for the network level
that says there are multiple solutions
producing very similar behavior
but it's easy to see in the single cell
so we have six models
a b c d e f
their behavior is very similar but now
if we look at the a current the purple
see it's tiny in model a and it's giant
in model f if you look at the calcium
activated k
here you see it here when it's firing
and you can see here it's firing so and
if you look carefully you don't have
time to look carefully but if you were
to look carefully you'll see
all sorts of other interesting
differences and behaviors
and for example the h-current
is quite different than all these models
so
this tells you again that you get very
similar
behavior with different sets of
parameters and then that immediately
sets you up to ask a whole series of
questions
and i usually show the next slide after
showing you astrid prince
network version of the same solution
but we'll do it without that so
question is how variable the parameters
in real biological networks
do perturbations reveal cryptic animal
to animal differences
how reliably can animals with intrinsic
variability
respond to perturbations and then are
some sets of parameters associated with
higher resilience
and we more or less know the answers to
these three questions
or at least partial answers this is
something
we still don't understand and obviously
this is the big payoff
for understanding the human condition
and resistance disease or resistance to
educational malfeasance etc
or war okay so what do we know
um i'm skipping all the old stuff and i
just like to show you
some pcr data that it's a collaboration
between dave schultz the university of
missouri he was a postdoc in my lab
and us looking at single neuron
pcr data for the 20 or 22
different voltage dependent currents or
channel genes
that we see um expressed in these
neurons so this is
single pd neurons that have been hand
dissected
and you can see that here's bkkca that's
one of the
um that codes one of the proteins for
the calcium activated
okay here's hcn that's for ih um
we've got some of the calcium currents
we've got
shab shaker and shell that's all shaw
these are all
ia and the delight rectifier etc
so what you see in all of these and this
has we've done this
myriad of times in different ways is
that there's about a two to six two to
seven fold
variance both in the mrna expression
levels
in the voltage clamp measurements of
single
channel on single um voltage dependent
currents
and also in synaptic strains
so we see everything that we can measure
parameter by parameter has this range
of variance which is about two to six
two to seven fold
nonetheless if you just put together raw
controlled data from five animals like
adrian
atopic did here you can see the motor
patterns are very very similar
so underneath all these motor patterns
if we were now taking up
to take out the pd cells we would see
this variability in the expression of
channel genes
and and that's true in the lp and this
two and the p y is two and all
okay so individual synaptic and
intrinsic parameters can vary two to six
fold across animals
even when they have very similar
behavior and i think this is this two to
six fold i think is a real
interesting number because i think it
holds true for
for all preparations and it's because of
the
um i think you can't tune um
too tightly i think it's a really
important sort of balancing act
that the nervous system has found to do
this
okay so now when i first started talking
about these individual differences
people started asking me well what
happens with perturbations because
even though you have these
whoops these individual
differences you might expect a pd cell
with an a current or without an a
current and one with a really large
acura
to respond differently to perturbations
or you might excel
and that's certainly even more true at
the level of the circuit so
we've been trying to
study a number of perturbations in
particular we were curious about
the if you have multiple solutions if
every crab has a different set of
underlying
properties you might expect that at some
point there will be a perturbation there
has to be perturbation
that will separate or distinguish among
those cells and that's
true but the question is can animals
which have nonetheless
this variety or this variance in their
underlying structures
can they respond reliably to the
perturbations they see
so the perturbations we've been studying
are temperature and some of you probably
heard me about this
heard me talk about this temperature is
a global perturbation that influences
all biological processes
but importantly it does so
differentially so the relationships
among processes will be altered
since every voltage dependent
conductance
may respond differently to temperature
as
the the same currents and the calcium
currents the potassium currents
are altered differently you might expect
the dynamics of neurons to change
or become dysfunctional
now ph is again quite
relevant to the life of animals in the
ocean
as well as to your tissues and high
potassium and high potassium is
obviously
a way of producing a global
depolarization
of all the tissues this is relevant to
some human pathologies and it's
certainly something that
that people in the lab do all the time
so this will become interesting for
those of you
who use high potassium as a way of
manipulating membrane potential etc so
we'll start with temperature
we describe acutan as the
snapshot of describing the exponential
change in a rate as a function of
temperature q10 of 1
means everybody is constant
most of the conductances and neurons
have q10s between the two to four range
so there's a strong exponential there
except for the ion channels that are
important for temperature
sensing and these can have q10s that are
20 or 50 or 100
so they can be exquisitely temperature
sensitive but most of the normal
conductances
are between 1.5 and 4.
but they're not all the same and that's
important so
when lamont tang was a graduate student
he did the first experiments in our lab
about this
so here's the pyloric rhythm at 7
degrees at 19 degrees
and then you can see the frequencies
gone up
but nonetheless the phase relationships
that is to say
the turning on and turning off of each
of the cells in the cycle
the relationships are maintained
constantly
and that's what's important for the
function of the pyloric rhythm
just as it's important if you want to
walk that you'd be able to
activate your extensors and your flexors
of the two
of your two legs etc in the right timing
relationships this is
i mean so the timing relationships are
maintained even though the frequency has
changed a lot
okay and this was in lamont's first set
of experiments
he went up to about 23 to 24 degrees and
as long as he went up to
from about seven to about 24 degrees 23
to 24 degrees
the rhythms were beautifully maintained
and the phase would be
beautifully maintained however when in
these first studies
he went much higher um he went up to 28
degrees
etc he got all these different kinds of
crashes
and every single animal crashed
differently and it's crashing
differently as what you'd expect if each
one of them had a different subset of
of underlying conductances so the
take-home lesson of this
was that all of those different
solutions worked
fine for the temperature changes that
those crabs would see in the ocean
in the ocean they see temperatures from
about three degrees normally to about 25
degrees
and they can see a 10 degree change in
temperature in the in a single day
these animals are go from being
intertidal to be going down to about
600 feet so these are temperatures
in winter to summer that they would
normally see so however
28 degrees they all were crashing and
they were all crashing differently and
this
made complete sense to us because that's
exactly what you'd predict
for this kind of perturbation however
several years later the
the winter of 2012. sarah haddad was a
graduate in the lab and she did the
experiment again
and she was able to go from 11 degrees
to 36 degrees
and you can see there's no crash here
the pyloric rhythm is just going faster
faster and faster at first i thought the
sierra had messed up
because i thought and then she pointed
out to me that
the rhythm was going six or seven hertz
here and i'd never seen a
six or seven hertz rhythm um and then we
figured out
that that winter the ocean was
unbelievably warm
it was six to six to seven degrees
warmer than normal and later we
discovered
from the guys at woods hole that the
squid had all gone to maine the dogfish
had all gone to maine
and that these crabs that we were seeing
here had overwintered in a way too warm
winter so this is a long-term
environmental adaptation now either it
means that these are the animals that
didn't die
in the too warm winter or that these
guys just
so that you had six months of
adaptation acclimation to the high
temperatures
the following year the crash points went
back down
however this past year we also had very
temperature resistant we also had
animals that were producing pyloric
rhythms up at 36 degrees
so we now keep track of every last
animal when we got it what day
what what we and we keep track of the of
the surface temperatures in the water
and we're trying to see if we we sort of
discovered that we're
we're sort of become environmental
biologists despite ourselves
now the reason i'm showing you this is
if i had just shown you
this 11 degree trace it looks
virtually identical to these 11 degree
traces
and there's absolutely no way we would
have ever
known that this was
a ganglion that could go to 36 degrees
and that probably many of these
could not so this is what i would call
cryptic data you know if if you don't
stress the animals
you just do your control recordings your
control you don't actually know that
something has changed
until you actually do the manipulation
that reveals the change
and i think this is really important as
we start thinking about what is a
control
for all of our experiments you know what
is it that you need to know about the
life history of the animals
and i think raising them in the same
cages in the lab probably doesn't count
i don't it's probably not good enough
anyway
so to move on um i'd just like to show
you
now a couple of experiments using
the dynamic clamp to create
a half center oscillator we talked about
half center oscillates before
that's reciprocal inhibition and
what this work was done by katja
morozova
and we're just writing this up right now
so she's working on two gm neurons those
are two neurons in this demanding
ostrich and they're part of the gastric
mild rhythm
when isolated they're completely silent
and then she uses a dynamic clamp to
create they're not synaptically coupled
to the
to each other or anybody else she uses a
dynamic clamp
so these are biological neurons to add
synapses inhibitory synapses between the
two of them
and h conductances to each of the cells
so the dynamic clamp includes a computer
and in the computer you have a program
of the modeled current
and so basically you record from the
cell
and you say at that membrane potential
what current would flow through the
model current and then the computer
injects that current
back into that cell so basically this
allows you to add or in principle
subtract
conductances at will so here koch is
using it
to create two synaptic conductances and
to add ih
to the cells so here you see now
these two cells become active
in alternation and they make a beautiful
half center oscillator
and you see in two different conditions
an escape condition and a release
condition
so and what koch has done to put it
either into an escape mode or a waste
mode
is in the computer she's changed the
threshold for synaptic release
from hyperpolarized from about minus 52
to more depolarized i think it's more
like -34
so here the cells start releasing
transmitter
at -50 and here they don't start
they they release transmitter until
whenever they're above minus 30 whatever
so in this case we have an escape near
the hyperpolarized cell
because of ih starts depolarizing it
crosses the transition and so it starts
firing
and inhibits the other cell now the
inhibited cell
gets escapes from that inhibition
because of ih
and then that accounts for this
transition in this case because of where
the synaptic threshold is
the cell that's up the on cell
is releasing transmitter until it shows
some spikes
frequency adaptation it falls below the
synaptic release
threshold and then it stops releasing
transmitter that allows the other cell
to start firing
and so this is called the release mode
this is called the escape mode
and both of these work and you if you
just had an extracellular recording
you would say these two cells are firing
in antiphase
and that would be it so these networks
look very similar
but katya discovered that the escape
oscillators are here are very
temperature resistant so here's a
beautiful half center
and she's taking it from i don't know
10 degrees up to 20 degrees
and you can see there's almost no change
in frequency
and virtually it's more or less
temperature and variant and you see that
in the spectrogram down here
in contrast
in release mode you can see so
she starts out with uh you can see you
start out at low temperatures with
really
um excellent behavior and then you have
a crash here
and then when she goes back down in
temperature she has a recovery
and now so that tells you that the
underlying mechanism that's producing
the oscillation
is actually changing its sensitivity to
a perturbation
um and then in this case you see
again she starts out over here
with a half center activity and as she
increases the temperature she goes from
being
more or less in an escape mode to be in
a release mode
and that happens because the cells start
depolarizing
and as the cells depolarize the position
of the synaptic threshold
relative to the cell's behavior changes
and so you have a transition in behavior
so here you have an increase in
temperature which switches the mechanism
the oscillation
from escape to release and i think this
is really important because
the same kind of thing could easily
happen in a modulator
okay and now i'm going to show you my
favorite slide of the year
this is a picture of
a simulation that leanjo did
where he's looking in a burst at the
last spike of the burst
at 10 degrees and at 25 degrees
and what you see here is that
the a current which is in purple starts
out large and gets smaller and smaller
and smaller and smaller
and so 25 is small and it's large
at 10. and in orange you see the calcium
k
gets larger and larger and larger and
larger
so the mechanism of spike repolarization
here
is completely different from the
mechanism here
but the neuron in this case a model but
real neurons do the same thing the
neuron has managed to
smoothly move through these variable
mechanisms
as a function of the perturbation and so
my current working hypothesis
is that the reason we have so many
different
potassium channels and calcium channels
in single cells
is that when you have over when you when
you
tile in time and voltage you can make
smooth transitions
in behavior and that for the nervous
system to be robust or resilient to
perturbation
you have to smoothly be able to move
through mechanisms
like we did here or
we did there but this is a particularly
elegant way of seeing
that you smoothly through move through
mechanisms
okay now i'm gonna skip these
and move quickly to ph
so jess haley was uh worked in my lab
for a year and she worked two years and
she did this work
and we were curious about ph because
these animals deal with
ph effects in the ocean and
so here's a control ph seven eight and
now we're seeing just went to more and
more acid
and you can see the rhythm is very
very robust to it and now here's seven
eight again
and then she goes base and you can see
again it's very very robust
so i was really shocked at how robust
these
gang they were to the changes in
extracellular ph
obviously what really matters what their
how these cells are managing to maintain
their intracellular ph but
they do have there's no animal here it's
just the nervous system
but jacob ratliff did a really cool
experiment
um and he wanted to ask a question that
many of you have in your mind
which is what happens when you combine
ph and temperature or will you combine
different perturbations
and does an animal are is an animal
robust to all perturbations
or is there trade-off between being
robust to one perturbation
and being more sensitive to another so
now
jacob here is just recording from the
pacemaker neurons the isolated pd's
and so here are three experiments um
and so this is the pv as he's making
very small changes in temperature
he's right next to the crash point and
you can see the crash point is slightly
different
for the three animals but in all cases
he goes from bursting to
to sort of sub threshold oscillations to
basically being off
and this is with ph however i mean
temperature however with ph
as he goes from ph 7 down to ph 6
you can see you go from bursting to low
amplitude bursting to
spiking to tonic firing to silence
so the mode of transition is different
in ph and it is than it is in
temperature
and we thought this was really
interesting that this oscillator would
go through these different kinds of
bifurcations
these two different perturbations and
this just
pulls together a bunch of experiments
this is like i don't know 12
or so experiments and the
transition points are different
different temperatures
but with temperature at pha 2
they all go from bursting to silent
directly
whereas with ph they go from bursting
to tonic activity to silence
and then if you do different
combinations of the two together
you see that that set of transitions is
maintained
whether you do it at different ph's or
different temperatures
so these two different kinds of
bifurcations seem to be
triggered by these different um
perturbations
now i'm just very quickly going to show
you some results with high potassium
and i've never shown these before so
you're in for a treat
so this is work that louie he
was now a graduate student at harvard
did with
mara who's one of my graduate students
in cacho marzova
and the first paper was published last
year um
so here we're looking at a pd cell
and you put it they put it into high
potassium
and the whole network went silent but
then if you keep it in high potassium
it recovers activity and we were
surprised about this
and so so here you have the impact
circuit
it goes silent and then it recovers but
if you look at the isolated pd cell
it changes its excitability
it shifts its threshold but it doesn't
go quite
as silent as the intact circuit so part
of this is due to
the inhibition in the survey but
but recently mars done repeated
applications of high potassium so here
we have
high potassium now here's the spike
raster
so again you see you depolarize you go
silent
and then even though you still
depolarize this is important
the activity comes back and it doesn't
go back to its starting resting
potential until you wash
so it starts bursting even in sustained
high potassium
and what what's different across animals
is this duration
of the inhibition so
however when mara now does it again
in the same preparation you can see
it's much less likely to go silent
and it recovers much faster and
that's seen in these rasters
in the first application you have the
silence
and then the tonic activity and then
bursting
in the second application much less
silence
a little bit of tonic activity and then
bursting the last
one and never really even goes silent or
atomic
just stays bursting and this now pulls
together
many experiments so these are 14 animals
you can see the amount of time they go
silent differs
across the population but they all show
decrease in activity either very extreme
or less extreme
but eventually they recover bursting by
and large
and the second application gives you
less effect than the first and the third
even less
than the second and first so
and that's just shown there in the pool
data
so whatever has happened in that first
application is carrying over
and so then mara decided to figure out
how long did they remember the previous
exposure
so application one application two
application three
now this is a three hour wash and then
a test application after three hours and
you can see
a short a much shorter response than you
would have seen in the same animal there
and you can see that these responses
are far less complete than these
responses
so this is telling you that this
sustained depolarization
the animal the networks are recovering
from
but they're remembering that prior
experience or they're maintaining that
prior experience
so i'm just gonna end now and just with
a few
comments under control conditions in
response to many perturbations all
networks are well behaved
they do remarkably well in ph
temperature and even in high potassium
each individual animal crashes with
individual dynamics
as you'd predict individuals with
starting similar circuit performance
with relatively similar circuit
mechanisms
in the control state can nonetheless
show entirely different crash mechanisms
and this is a really cautionary for
thinking about disease and then
i would just like to say that
differential resilience in the
population is a necessary feature
that comes from the inherent degeneracy
of multiple solutions producing similar
behavior in healthy nervous systems
some mechanisms for differential
resilience are automatic
and arise from properties of ion
channels temperate receptors and
signaling
some will require homeostatic mechanisms
behavioral adaptation and learning
and then i would just like to end with
one more statement
if you randomly sample parameter space
it's
very difficult to find neurons that are
temperature compensated
they're not common in the population we
have to search really hard
to find them so we speculate that the
biological systems do not randomly
sample
parameter space but fixed correlations
and we have very strong correlations are
imposed by
transcription factors and other
molecular events so the diverse
solutions all these multiple solutions
are stay on a preferred manifold that
gives rise to successful behavior
and i'll stop there and thank you for
your attention thank you very much eve
that was
that was really fabulous um i would like
to invite everybody to
um ask questions in the q a
box if you have any questions for eve
and while you do that eve i'll i'll
start by asking you a question i know
you've thought a lot
about the kind of homeostatic mechanisms
that might be involved
in uh producing these these effects that
you talk about
um i think that's particularly
intriguing in the case of the
uh the resilience to the potassium
uh concentration changes that you just
uh showed us
can you say a little bit about the kinds
of mechanisms that you think are
involved
in those homeostatic regulation
okay so what i didn't show you
because i was kind it's a brand new
homeostatic model that leandro alonso
has built
specifically for the high potassium um
mechanism so what what leandro had to do
is he had to find models that would
distinguish between
homeostatic models that would
distinguish well between
bursting telling firing and silence
and it turns out there are just a
variety of technical
issues around the different kinds of
homeostatic models that we had been
studying
so he modified the lewitol model which
was published in 1998 which has three
calcium sensors
his three calcium feedbacks but that
model tends to blow up
over time so he put a bound on the
conductances to prevent that
and then to get the long-term memory
what he did is he did something very
clever and i think this is probably real
and we're
we're writing this now what he did is
he's
gating the homeostatic mechanism on and
off
so when the network is close to its
homeostatic targets
the calcium sensors are saying okay
you're close to your targets you don't
have to do very much you can hang out
and when you start to deviate it turns
on the homeostatic mechanism
so it works much harder and this allows
you to build in
time scales for intermittent
homeostatic recovery and so this model
actually works extremely well
to capture the long the
the slower memories of the gaps because
otherwise the old models you'd wash out
all of that stuff
in the long time periods so i don't know
if that answered your question
but that was great i have i have many
other questions about those
homeostatic mechanisms they're they're
it's just absolutely fascinating
um let me just read a couple of
questions from
uh that have come in on the q a so the
first one is from mark harnett
uh beautiful talk eve thank you i was
struck by the
idea of smoothness in the transition of
ion channel activations in response to
the perturbations
how do you think about this interacting
with the rate
of the perturbation as opposed to its
magnitude in other words
i i think the question is how does that
interact with the
rate at which the perturbation is
imposed
um i'm not exactly
sure for all of them so
in the ones we did well in
in leandro's models he he would probably
ramp up
i mean not terribly slowly because have
you ever found a theorist who'll do
anything too slowly
right they're too impatient um but it
would still
would be you would ramp it up more
slowly
than the burst period probably
um so i don't exactly know
i would expect that the answer to that
would depend exactly on the details
of of the model um but
obviously if you're going to tile in
voltage and time you don't want to make
incredibly fast transitions but then
probably
we don't need to do very fast
transitions most of the time
so i don't know we could look at that we
just never have done
just like with experiences it'll depend
on how fast you go up and down
right um another question this one from
phil sharp have you been able to
determine
if protein synthesis is involved in the
adaptations that you see
so so here's the thing
i hate to say this to a molecular
biologist but i will
many years ago we tried to figure out
for some of these ion channel genes and
for all mrna
how quickly the mrna was turning over
and we tried blocking everything we
could block
and we always we were never able to
figure out how fast most of the mrnas
were
going away so our current feeling is
that because these are cold water
animals
and because they're very long-lived that
these rnas hang around
for a while that is to save days
they're not flipping okay they're you
know we can't deplete them very quickly
that
said within two hours
we see very clear up regulation of
heat shock genes and interestingly
the heat shock genes that
are upregulated are different
depending on whether we look at
temperatures some of them are the same
and some are different
whether we look at temperature
or high potassium or changes in ph
so we have a differential regulation of
heat chuck
with these different perturbations all
in all cases we have regulated heat
shock
so we're assuming that the heat shock up
regulation
is a two-hour process so presumably over
many hours you can get changes in
all of the transcription translation etc
good thank you um here's a question i'm
going to
just paraphrase um are all of the
homeostatic mechanisms operating at a
single cell level
or is there is something more akin to
network level homeostasis going on
so there are two ways of answering that
one way is that in all of our models and
all the
experimental work we've done it's pretty
clear that there must be homeostatic
mechanisms
that operate at the single cell level
and it's
almost certainly the case that many of
those mechanisms
can percolate up to the network level
now whether there are network level
mechanisms that depend on
long loops like sensory feedback and
stuff like that
to tell you that you're off your target
we don't really know
but certainly in this system
because this is a motor system and
because there are sensory
neurons that respond to its output you
could also imagine
long-looped effects
that in which sensory neurons are
activating modulatory neurons and those
modulatory neurons are influencing
the homeostatic mechanisms so
we don't really know um
but what we really do need to figure out
is to what extent
the cellular level single cell stuff
really can account for
network level behaviors and thus far
at the level of the pyloric rhythm it
probably can do that
what's less clear which is why we're so
interested in
leandro's work with a high potassium is
the gastric mill rhythm
is intermittent so the
simple kinds of homeostatic mechanisms
that we were originally modeling
can't account for you turning on the
gastric mill rhythm and getting it right
and being on for an hour and then
turning off for three days and then
turning it back on and being right for
an hour
there's too much delay in there so it's
clear that we would need a different
kind of homeostatic model to do that
which is partly why we're so interested
in the idea of turning on and turning
off these processes
does that make sense whoever asked that
okay good um we're going to
try um we have a few questions here but
i wanted to give a few people the
opportunity to ask their questions live
so ann had a question for you ann
graybiel
um and can you um unmute yourself and
try to ask your question
hi anne hi there it's uh absolutely
magnificent talk
thank you for my following look that
i was of course fascinated by the
homeostasis and all the local mechanisms
and so on
and also you're you're conclusion
that a random
choice kind of mechanism
wouldn't work in the end things have to
have evolved
to a certain extent you can't just
randomly
[Music]
sample that great bridge he was showing
so on the other hand for
uh people who work on mammals and there
is
none the non-human primate work
they can take the activity of the
apparently randomly chosen promoter
neurons and
say an attack frontal lobe and
they can have them move a robot arm
maybe not
elegantly but pretty well or they can
pick up
the activities of the few neurons
in the intertemporal cortex and using
their activity
identify for example the future of the
face
so how do you get these different levels
to how do you relate them in your mind
i understand the different levels of
analysis and i'm looking
at a question for uh
obviously huge networks right right
but it's just random business that i
mean we know this you know right
in a number of cases it's quite
remarkable think of the word
glory joy in new york well but you know
all of those neurons so i guess we have
to step back and say
within one cell type you're going to see
i believe that same two to six-fold
range
in sodium channels and potassium
channels and glutamate receptors
but neurons of that cell type are still
different from neurons of a different
cell type
so they're going to be sitting on this
wide but constrained manifold
let's say i'm a neuron of x-cell type
and if i'm a neuron of that cell type
i make a projection to some other area
in the brain
and it's the projection that really
defines that cell type
probably as much as the channel so i
would say if you're picking individuals
from the same cell type that's
projecting to the same general area
um it might look random but it still
would not be
random as if you know they they all
would have some characteristic
properties if they were isolated if you
were seeing them in isolation
i guess i mean i think that two to six
fold is really really important
because it means that you could find
neurons that actually
vary to some degree in their fi curves
or in the strength of their connections
but nonetheless they can be part of a
functional circuit
with defined um consequences am i making
sense
um is that what you were asking
no i know i was it was a wild question
but it's very interesting to hear your
answer
i agree that i'm fascinated by that
range
here to solve 3-7 yeah because
i think you know and i think it's a sort
of a magic number because
you know it's hard to imagine building a
neuron that's going to be stable for 100
years
where every ion channel or every
membrane protein or every protein
has to be tuned within point one percent
right it's just too hard
well should we you if i would it's too
hard
right and in biology there's so many
errors
right you have to be tolerant you have
to be fall tall and to some degree
okay the question was actually
based on what we're just talking about
now there's so many errors
so the ultimate error would be for
scientists
with old fashioned elections
what's that noise okay so yes
so i think that two to six fold is very
fundamental
because i think we see it everywhere and
i think it's because it's
it's the balance between so noisy
that you're so poorly constrained that
you can't do anything
and so tightly controlled that you can't
do it in biological systems over long
periods of time
so it gives you the slop it gives you
the workable
slop range now there could be
and it could be in some neurons you have
to be more tightly tuned than
others for example auditory neurons that
would nearly fire very fast
maybe you have to be a little bit more
tightly constrained there i don't know
or maybe not
um michael maybe you have an opinion
whether your highest frequency auditory
neurons have to be more tightly
regulated
i don't know um i'm not sure i was going
to turn the last question over to one of
our students um
eve if that's okay um carla are you um
are you able to um
let's see katherine maybe you can
just one second let me get carla there
hi can everyone here go ahead and ask go
ahead and ask your question
thank you so much for your for your talk
i really appreciated the cautionary tale
aspect and i think another person on the
chat also has a similar question so for
the
in general how well controlled is the
gastric circuit in terms of noise so you
were just talking about noise
being you know is it on the order of the
perturbations
or do you think that in a natural
environment um
you're actually getting more
perturbation than what you could make in
a lab
um and also like how did you control for
that in the computational parts of the
experiment so how did you kind of
connect it to them so um
you know depending on on what kind of
work you do
noise is just what you don't know about
so for example i'd just like to remind
you
that leak in neurons used to be
everything that we didn't know
and it was jumbled into the leak and
then as more and more currents were
better defined
things came out of the leak and turned
into other things
so noise in terms of the gastric mill
rhythm
i guess i don't know how to answer that
exactly
there is some amount of cycle to cycle
variability
but then the other piece that i didn't
tell you about
these are all motor neurons and they are
driving muscles and the muscles are slow
integrators
so a lot of the noise whether um
a burst has eight extra potentials or
nine
extra potentials and seven extra
potentials that all is going to
disappear
by the time you get to the muscle
movement because you're putting a slow
filter on the back end of the
the jitter at the at the neural level um
so the muscles are moving
more slowly they there's a lot of
facilitation
summation of the level of muscle so
you know that actually is taking out a
lot of the a lot of the noise in the
at the neural level and
the other piece that takes out a lot of
the noise and i didn't tell you this
either
these neurons release transmitter as a
graded function of membrane potential
so almost all of the transmitter release
is coming from the slow wave
and not from the spike times so
any jitter in spike timing in the
in the actual pattern generator network
again it goes away
because the slow wave is much more
reliable than
so the spike timing is not there
terribly important to the pattern
generation
in the network and it's not terribly
important for
for the for the muscle movements
so you've got slow waves and you've got
a slow integrator on the back end
and so you're sort of buffered against
slight differences in spike timing
so um i think that in the lab we have
probably about as much noise as they
have in the in the animal the animal has
a lot of hormones floating around
um but i have a lot of undergraduates
floating around so
that was a joke they hope
they don't usually spin into my dish i
hope
i don't know about your answer yeah
thank you carla um let me just squeeze
in one more question
uh this is from jill crittenden
do you think these circuits are more
resistant to perturbations that
typically occur in the crab or lobster
home environment
are they more robust to those than
stressors that are experienced in
different environments maybe that the
animal doesn't experience
well i don't know what ex what stressors
i can give my animals
they don't see so these guys remember
they see changes in temperature they see
changes in ph they see
changes in oxygen tension they see
changes in co2 levels
they see changes in
seagull behavior flying above their
heads
they see changes in industrial effluent
right i mean the ones
i don't know i don't know what to do i
mean the high potassium is probably the
closest thing
to something that they don't normally
see although
i guess they can have high potassium
buildup
under certain physiological conditions
as well um
i don't know what stressor i could give
them i guess one
one example hi eve thank you so much for
the talk i
mean one thing that made me think of it
was your finding of this
perhaps change over time i mean you said
it could be a sampling difference but
with the warmer oceans
oh yeah well that's that's but that
yeah i mean it's it's been known for a
very long time that there are
slow acclamations all marine animals
show slow acclamation to
you know temperature in particular
so but the literature says
that acclimation is supposed to take
three to four weeks and then we did
acclimation experiments in the lab
we went for three to four weeks and we
saw some changes but we didn't see the
kind of changes that we saw
over six months in the ocean so i think
there must be
acclimation at the time scale of the
three to four weeks and then there must
be this really slow
acclamation that takes place over many
months
unless that we're now seeing
animals that came north from virginia
and our animals all went to maine i
don't think crabs migrate that way
but you could imagine that some virginia
animals managed to come
north and that some of our animals went
to maine
and the other animals that couldn't deal
with the high temperatures just died
so we don't know that's why i said we
don't know where they're coming or
the other thing is these animals all
have some temperature preference and so
they can be moving around in their
habitats
but um
so i don't know thank you well maybe
it's good news we've just evolved uh
resistance to
everything then right because these old
circuits are
half at all so yeah but you know what
they do
but they're not resistant to is there's
certain kinds of shell diseases
that in particular lobsters get that can
wipe out whole populations
so i think there's a difference i think
it's important there's probably a real
difference
pathogens that do things like
destroy the shell
and and these environmental swings
that don't actually kill the animals
but i don't know i never thought i'd
become a climate scientist
but you know one of my students is
literally keeping track of
you know and we're trying to track and
we're actually really trying to track
the heat shock response throughout the
year
to see how the heat shock response
changes
through as a response of ocean
temperature
well thank thank you eve thank you um uh
for everybody who asked questions
and uh let's give eve uh another virtual
round of applause eve thank you so much
for a fabulous thank you so much
and and phil thank you for everything
you've done for neuroscience and
if you're still there thank you for this
as well
bye guys